hallo ich meine lieben freund und
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen folge
minecraft galaxy
ich hab für heute noch mental ein
stühlchen so warte ich muss erst mal ich
verstehe ich nicht wieso muss ich immer
wieder diesen shader neue reinpacken mir
wurden trotz dessen ich das in der ein
stunden folge gesagt habe dass es mir
egal ist dass ich auch nur alle fünf
blöcke mal wasser machen könnte wurde
mir das ganze auch gesagt du kannst nur
alle fünf tage wasser machen ja ich weiß
ich bin das so schöner
ich finde das wirklich so schöner da ist
es mir relativ egal wie sinnvoll das ist
fast da gemacht hat aber ich fand das so
einfach schöner ich brauche auf jeden
fall noch ein bisschen glas deswegen
wollte ich mir ein wenig sand noch
putzen auf jeden fall noch mehr sand
meer sand aus mehr so hatte ich mal eben
eine schaufel meine stimme ist auch ein
wenig angeschlagen
er hört es ich bin ein bisschen heiser
woran das weiß ich nicht ich bin ich
habe sehr lange geschlafen aber ich bin
halt wirklich gerade erst aufgestanden
deswegen ist die facetime auch total
viel zu hell fällt mir grad auf aber ich
habe jetzt kann das alles umzustellen
das tut mir auf jeden fall los ist
übrigens ich weiß nicht ob ich das sagen
darf aber ich lasse es jetzt einfach mal
ich weiß nicht vielleicht alles schon
gesagt irgendwie so dass er nicht mehr
dabei ist ich will jetzt nicht spoilern
oder irgendwie sowas
ich muss auch mal gucken aber egal ich
werde mir alles hinkriegen da wollte ich
denn sagen ich wollte sagen dass ich
zurzeit am ganzen vorproduzieren dran
bin weil ich ja vom 30 bis zum 17 weg
bin
die sache ist ich hab da wo ich bin kein
internet das heißt die musik alles voll
produzieren die scheiße an diesem
vorproduzieren ist ich kann ich richtig
four produzieren weil bei mir dort einen
upload einfach drei stunden und das
heißt ich habe mir aufgeschrieben dass
jeden tag ein video kommt das sind dann
zehn videos acht videos und diese acht
videos allerdings dauern bei mir zum
hochladen acht mal drei sind 24 stunden
das heißt pcs 420 stimmen durchgängig
hoch das wird ja hoffentlich an dem tag
machen wo ich auch abreise und also an
dem montag an dem neben dem 30 33
das ist glaube ich saß am montag das am
sonntag ich weiß gar nicht jedenfalls
wenig gerade der ganze die ganze zeit
dabei einem vorproduktion ich hab schon
also es wird wirklich nur jeden tag
wiederkommen ich ermessen will also
nicht es ist es wird nicht so sein dass
jeden tag nur galaxy kommt
wir haben hier also fenster es wird
nicht so sein dass jeden tag nur galaxy
kommt sondern ich habe da ein paar
andere sachen noch mit drin wie
beispielsweise der kontakt zur infekt
sind dann noch mit drin
eine modifikation ist da drin und ein
neues projekt mit gommel kann ich euch
schon mal sagen das wird richtig richtig
cool
da freue ich mich jetzt schon so immens
drauf also ich hab echt richtig bock auf
dieses neue bot diese scheiß wollten
dass wir diese wolke heraus video
settings die teils klart auf
ich freue mich richtig auf das projekt
mit kommen das wird richtig cool ich
habe das auch noch nicht in deutschland
gesehen aber ich freue mich da so immens
drauf da habe ich richtig richtig bock
auf das projekt ist es kein engagement
ich will euch nicht zu viel verraten
sagen wir es mal so und das wird auf
jeden fall richtig cool das wird auch
noch losgehen in der zeit wo ich weg bin
und das nehme ich morgen mit ihm auf
also wenn ihr das video seht gerade
wirklich morgen und ich muss halt alles
ein bisschen plan ich das alles
aufnehmen weil ihr wisst es aber schon
wieder viel zu viel
london games pacific zeugs hier
das sind immer so ankündigungs folgen
hier ich mache das jetzt schon als ende
bringen
ihr wisst ich habe jetzt heute habe ich
entlassfeier
vom abi der blog dann habe ich morgen
also heute entlassfeier und danach gehen
wir mit einer anderen familie zusammen
essen das wird richtig cool und morgen
ist mein abi ball und dann abiball ist
natürlich immer so die einzige party wo
wenn man da nicht durch macht dann hat
man irgendwas falsch nicht mit dem was
ich verstanden leben also wir machen auf
jeden fall alle durch und dann bin ich
quasi bis 6 uhr wach wir gehen dann alle
zusammen frühstücken becker und dann
schlaf ich den ganzen tag und dann
fahren wir nachts um 3 uhr nach
bulgarien los also dann wird mein schlaf
rhythmus wieder komplett gefegt sein
aber das ist ja eh schon von daher traut
ihm das zu dass er das in gepackt mein
schlaf rhythmus und das wird auf jeden
fall richtig witzig ich werde in
bulgarien auf jeden fall ein paar sachen
film nicht direkt hochladen sondern dann
irgendwie ein zwei wochen später
vielleicht daher kein internet habe und
ja ich muss halt gucken wie das ganze
dann halt so ablauf mit ich hoffe dass
ich alles passend vor produzieren kann
ich liebe dich ich liebe das immer so
was wie vor produzieren zu reden weil
dadurch dass ich darüber rede mache ich
mir insgeheim sondern planen wie ich das
alles mache weil ich das aufnehmen und
so dass ich ganz gut aber ich hätte zu
versuchen mal so ein bisschen wieder
hierbei das spiel zu quatschen ein
bisschen wieder wasser auf die team
vernünftiges und ich mir ein paar möbel
ja machen
ein tisch und soll ich den die in den
sand einfach mal dastehen lassen
ich lasse jetzt einfach mal stehen ich
habe schon genug jetzt wieder einen
stack armut gut so
die sonne geht schon wieder unterwegs
heimischer fünf minuten aufgenommen
brechen ihre möglichkeiten so ich mache
das hier oben dann einfach irgendwann
noch jetzt in dieser folge versucht
anzubauen
nächste woche kommen dann wahrscheinlich
keine 1 stunden folge weil ich es
einfach zeitlich nicht hinkriege obwohl
medien stunde folge echt gut gefallen
hat wenn ich jetzt gesagt hätte wohl die
ein stunden folge bei mir viel zu lange
viel zu langweilig da hätte ich gesagt
nee kommen dann keinen bock darauf aber
dadurch dass ich viele coole fragen
gestellt wurden und so war das ganze
echt ich sag mal erträglich und das
ganze war richtig richtig cool und am
ende als ich damals 50 minuten angelangt
war dachte mir so war okay wir sind bei
50 minuten ich dachte jetzt gerade noch
bild 20 minuten oder so dass eigentlich
richtig cool das hat mir richtig viel
spaß gemacht
nur ich hab halt gerade echt wenig zeit
in meinem leben drin dafür dass ich so
was jetzt noch mal die nächste woche man
kann natürlich jetzt noch mal kommen
bald werden dann noch live streams
kommen wenn ich in hamburg wohnen weil
nicht alle 50.000 leitung hat alles so
bleibt und dann sollte das eigentlich
alles klappen mit dem hochladen und so
weiter und so fort und ich hoffe einfach
wirklich dass das alles klappt dem
hochladen
das ist alles jetzt ein bisschen für
euch das video an und denkt euch so cool
dass du in urlaub fährt sagt uns nicht
tausend mal wir wissen's langsam planen
dein leben ja es geht ein bisschen kacke
mit meinem internet hat das nicht ein
bisschen scheiße ich habe schon überlegt
nach frankfurt zu fahren zu einem freund
und das dann da hochzuladen über die
fahrt nach frankfurt dauert vier stunden
und dann lohnt sich das quasi alles gar
nicht ich muss noch überlegen was ich
hier quasi für blöcke reinsetzen oder
der weg muss da auf jeden fall bleiben
muss der weg da bleiben wir wollen das
dann mache ich wollte die kisten immer
so ans ende stellen
dann muss jede wand rein aber dann passt
dass da auch nicht mit der wand verdammt
ich weiß wie ich das mache ich mache das
einfach so moment ich hab ihn planen
dann mache ich das ganze mich ein kürzer
ich dich hier weg die ich hier weg wie
ich hier weg ich nehme ich weg bekommt
zuerst rechts du bleibst da kommt auch
weg und du auch so dann kommt das hier
so hin
neue blöcke so jetzt mache ich hier die
reihe weg weil ich kein bock habt dass
ich zu viel paul mudter für wieder
verschwinde
hallo oder ich dass da wo liegen lassen
das ist eine ganze reihe party mit
flöten geht oder für das sich das ist
echt mal so ein chaos diese ganze
scheiße anzupflanzen mache ich das jetzt
einfach mal weg damit du an konturen
zack & club und duh und bund boots und
so ganz anfreunden braucht sich
eigentlich für das glas aber das ist so
es kommt hier parteien die mir kommt es
so vor als ob ich alles aus papenburg
bauen dass nach ein bisschen zu und
windig wird egal das wird schon alles
passen irgendwie wird schon alles gut
aussehen bei mir sieht alles super aus
eigentlich gar nix aber ja
fitschen hier kommt es auf alle hier mit
drogen dann kommen da ans ende nachher
ganz ganz viele kisten da muss mir noch
ganz ganz viele kisten machen
ihm ist da noch alle ein höher so
ankommt da oben noch voll motiviert man
davon habe ich das nicht schon vorher
alles ausgeknobelt beim einer
zwischenzeit kann ja mal ganz kurz mir
die kohle hier mitnehmen und dann die
kohle mit dem sand hat super gepasst
dass da ganz kohle war wird doch keine
fackeln hast du das immer wenn ich im
dunkeln abbau als ich kann im dunkeln
abbauen
aber ich mag das aber nie für die
zuschauer war ich dann immer zumute dass
ihr dieses dunkle quasi sehen müssen und
ich weiß genau dass youtube das ganze
immer noch mal dunkler macht man
deswegen gar nichts mehr erkennt nach
außen mal guckt vielleicht bei nacht
oder so aber ich spiele auch gerade mit
meinem hellichten tag das ganze ein
bisschen mit sand zu damit den export
oder so
verdammt
künstler weg und jetzt kommen auf welche
höhe kommen jetzt wirklich hier auf
diesen ein
man merkt dass ich gerade erst
aufgestanden bin ich muss echt ich hasse
mich dafür dass ich hasse mich dafür
dass ich das zehn millionen mal
ansprechen aber ich muss echt schauen ob
ich das alles schaffe mit dem hochladen
und mit dem auf dem wall es ist echt so
ich bin jeden tag jeden tag dauerhaft
weg mittlerweile jetzt dadurch das abi
ball und alles möglich ist das war es
auch schon wieder für diese folge will
jetzt alles setzt sich allzu lang machen
weil ich hoffe dass ich euch täglichen
die hochladen kann
ich pack mal ganz kurz den sand mit der
kohle in den ofen damit dass eventuell
bis zum nächsten folge 8 mio eur erhöhen
das sogar noch glas drin ein bisschen
setzt der stars war noch eben hin und
allgemein war ich finde dass ich schon
viel zu vielen folgen überzogen habe und
ich mich dann ein bisschen an die regeln
halten möchte so dann kommt hier noch so
ein komischer pfeiler hin und das hier
oben wird noch alles auf pump
das sieht doch ein bisschen komisch aus
wenn ihr alles offen ist das muss man
schon sagen da drunter kommt dann auch
noch palmroth teile also dann irgendwie
so mir das ganze glasklar so ein
bisschen den tieferen sinn hat wenn das
da nicht so in der luft schweben soll
darunter kommt auch noch so ein
komischer ein komisches powerboot teil
und dann brauche ich doch noch viel mehr
palmöl als ich gedacht hätte
na ja ich würde es mal sagen wenn es
euch gefallen hatte ich selbst mal
wieder drauf wenn es euch gefallen hat
zeigt man mit einer bewertung tut mir
leid dass diese folge und die nächsten
folgen vielleicht bisschen kürzer sind
aber ich versuche euch täglich eine
folge zu bringen und da würde ich sagen
sehen wir uns morgen bei galaxy 34
wieder